هذا المشروع هو جزء من
سلسلة من التجارب الخفيفة فقط في
كل مرة أقوم فيها فقط بإنشاء
شكل أو تركيبة
مختلفة ، وبالنسبة لي فهي أيضًا مجرد
تجربة بالنسبة لي للتلاعب
بالأضواء ومواد مختلفة البصريات
مثل المنشورات الكروية  وهي
حقًا مجرد طريقة لألعب حولها
هي أيضًا كلمة أخرى تحدد
مستقبلًا محتملاً ، لذا فإن هذا المشروع
ينظر حقًا إلى أه كانت هناك دول
ودول نامية
ويطرح السؤال أه هل يمكن لهذه الأماكن في الواقع بعد
100 عام من الآن  تطور تحول إلى
أه تعرف البلدان المتقدمة أو
البلدان التي يزدهر فيها الناس بالفعل ،
لذا فإن الصورة الأكبر لهذه القطعة
اليوم هي دعوة للناس
لإرسال قصصهم وإنشاء
رسوم متحركة ثلاثية الأبعاد وأفلام قصيرة معهم
والتعاون مع مؤلفي السيناريو
من الجميع  خلفيات مختلفة
وتمكين المبدعين حقًا باستخدام
تقنية مثل الذكاء الاصطناعي
خارج
[موسيقى] أجنبية
مع كل  الاحتجاجات والأشياء التي
تحدث في إيران ،
أعني أنني كنت أعمل في هذا الوسط
لفترة طويلة وأن أطباق الأقمار الصناعية
نوعًا ما تصور سطحًا في طهران
والناس يستخدمون أسطح المنازل
كأماكن للاحتجاج على بعض الأشخاص الذين
لا يذهبون  في الشوارع التي يستخدمونها ، يذهبون
إلى أسطح المنازل ويهتفون بأشياء مختلفة
، والآن بعد أن حدثت هذه الثورة
مع مقتل أمين
ناسا ، اعتقدت أن الوقت مناسب جدًا
لتقديم هذا التثبيت هنا في Nui
Blanche هو
[موسيقى]
تورنتو